these rear axle frames are made for VW
Phaeton and bentley luxury cars the
metallus of germany production line is
running at full capacity only 7 years
ago the plant was part of a family owned
company that went broke a private equity
firm stepped in but failed to get it
going again then two years ago Mexican
auto parts supplier Matassa came to the
rescue
una Technology La Punta this company had
core competence that would allow Matassa
to offer its customers top-quality we
were primarily interested in its close
contacts with the premium segments like
Audi Daimler and BMW Daimler even though
blue metal says biggest German plant is
in the small town of bag noise near
Cologne after years of uncertainty it's
1,300 employees are now hoping the
Mexican owner will secure the future of
the plant so far their experience has
been positive
they didn't just roll all over us and
try to impose their Mexican corporate
culture instead they took their time and
observed what's going on here how we
work and how the German market functions
continued we all wouldn't and even then
they made decisions they created
functions and structures and they
invested in our long-term success here
it's like the CEO of Apple Tom Matassa
invested 50 million euros in new
equipment like presses and laser cutting
machinery and they've promised to invest
an additional 40 million employees have
agreed to go without wage increases for
now the negotiations were tough and the
Mexican parent company implemented new
international work safety standards that
are much higher than they were under the
previous ownership step by step we're
getting to know German corporate culture
and how it's different than in Mexico
not only at the employee level but in
plant operations as well
we've integrated our procedures into the
operations from the old company but we
always look for practical solutions that
benefits everyone
and we'll implement them in all Matassa
locations the metal supplant is by far
the biggest employer in back noice dot
population twelve thousand local
residents are happy the old plant is
still running no matter where the new
owners come from